this video is sponsored by hp
hey everyone it's justine and today we
are checking out the hp elitebook 845 g9
powered by amd's latest ryzen pro 6000
series processors over the past few
years we have evolved the way that we
work and i was very excited when hp
reached out about taking a look at their
new elitebook 845 g9 i've covered a lot
of these various hp laptops in the past
and a lot of these devices cater towards
the business professionals or the
enterprise market it's starting more and
more to feel like those lines are
blurring between work home and
entertainment so devices that may have
once been considered for professionals
can all benefit from some of those
features
[Music]
so let's unbox it and see what is in
here
[Applause]
all right what do we have here we've got
some paperwork and of course we have our
laptop right here
still
absolutely love their new logo i know
it's been a while but still it's
perfection of course we've got our power
adapter
[Applause]
there you are
[Music]
oh i'm so excited to try this out i love
that this has a 16 by 10 aspect ratio
even though this is a 14 inch display
just that different aspect ratio i could
already tell that you're going to feel
like you have so much more screen real
estate let's plug it in get it all set
up
[Music]
and here it is the elitebook 845 g9
which has an amd ryzen pro 6000 series
processor battery life is something that
is very important for me when i'm
looking for devices to purchase and this
offers up to 26 hours on the 16 inch
version this is the 14 inch so you'll
get up to 18 hours of battery of course
that'll vary depending on what you're
doing but that's still pretty impressive
this is a 14 inch display with a 16 by
10 aspect ratio which will give you more
vertical access so that means less
scrolling than on a traditional 16x9
display you never realize how much of a
difference that makes until you're using
it for a while and then you go back to a
16x9 display this also means a larger
trackpad which is really nice when
working unplugged all day long one of
the real treats for me using this is all
of the ports that it has available on
this side you've got two usbc a usba and
an hdmi you can also spec this out with
an option to have a smart card reader
that would be located right here on the
other side we have a 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack usb a and an optional
external sim card slot as someone who is
always using so many different types of
usb devices i can say that i've enjoyed
having two usb a ports as an option
security is something that we should
care more about when it comes to
businesses it's a top priority so this
has hps always on security called wolf
security for business it creates a
hardware-enforced always-on
multi-layered security below in and
above the os to protect your pc from
threats couple that with amd pro
security features like amd memory guard
and you have a pc that helps protect
your most sensitive professional and
personal data now that we're starting to
head out of the house again and either
back to work or a coffee shop or
traveling this has the option of adding
4g lte built in so you won't have to
worry about searching for a wi-fi
connection if you're out but it does
also have wi-fi 6e and bluetooth 5.2 for
conference calls or online classes
there's a 5 megapixel camera with hp
auto frame powered by hp presence and
this can be customized in the settings
in the my hp app yeah i just ate
a really good dinner actually
it's more like a lunch but it's so loud
here like there's some music bumping can
you hear that um not really like there
might be music but i don't really hear
it
interesting because there's the new
voice isolation so when i talk do you
hear the music or do you not like what's
the what's it like
no i mean like i hear your voice
[Music]
the speakers are also pretty good with
bang and olufsen audio which goes great
with watching youtube videos movies
gaming or
i mean working
watching work presentations and work
email and homework right
right i also really love this feature
it's hp's ai-based noise cancellation
2.0 this allows your voice to be way
more isolated when you're talking in
busy locations like a coffee shop it'll
drown out the background and your voice
will be way more present for the person
on the other end
i also appreciate the fast charging on
this you'll be able to get a 50 charge
in just 30 minutes it happens way more
often than i'd like to admit that i
forget to charge my computer before i
have to leave so usually about a half
hour before i'll finally remember that i
didn't charge my computer last night so
that fast charge is definitely a nice
touch you're able to get this hp
elitebook in various configurations like
i mentioned earlier this is the 14-inch
but there's also a 13.3 inch and a 16
inch variation each one has different
rise and processor options and ram for
the 14 inch model you're able to
configure up to 64 gigabytes of
upgradable ddr5 ram and can choose
between a 38 or 51 watt hour battery
obviously changing things will make a
big difference in performance and
pricing so deciding what is most
important to you is always a good thing
to keep in mind
[Music]
[Applause]
these have bang olufsen speakers so
using that audio system it's delivering
a pretty loud sound i will say the bass
is not as prominent but as far as the
sound quality it sounds really good and
it's also very loud which i love because
i love editing without headphones if i
don't have to so just knowing that i'll
be able to get that audio not only while
i'm editing or working but for
conference calls listening to music or
you know just watching my own youtube
videos
[Applause]
[Music]
look look hey little fred hi
should i make a powerpoint about
squirrels
i could do that i like that this has a
taller aspect ratio so it is 16x10 as
opposed to 16x9 which is what most
displays are it also has a matte finish
on it which i love for working outside i
almost always take all my conference
calls i do a lot of my emails almost as
much as i possibly can i take my laptops
outside so to have a device that does
not have a reflective screen is
seriously the best thing ever because
the sun just glares down on your laptop
and it reflects back at you there's
reflections and with this i just see my
screen i don't see a lot of reflections
so definitely have been loving that
well i had a really fun time checking
out this hp elitebook 845 g9 this was
again the 14 inch model and this does
come in a bunch of other configurations
so if you guys want to see the full
lineup that they have available i'll put
a link in the description where you can
check that out again a huge thank you to
hp for partnering with me on this video
don't forget to subscribe if you haven't
already to my channel and be sure to hit
the bell so you'll be notified when i
post new videos i look forward to seeing
you guys in my next one bye
[Music]